Speaker 1: Let's now talk a little bit about.
The man who is the most likely to replace
Gavin Newsom in California if the vote to
recall him, decides to remove him.
So remember, it's sort of like a two part
vote in next week's California gubernatorial
recall.
The first thing is, do you want to remove
Gavin Newsom?
If the answer is no, that's it.
It's over.
Newsom stays and let's hope that takes place.
If the answer is yes, then there is a sort
of subsequent ballot where the question is,
well, who do you want to replace Gavin Newsom
with?
The guy who's leading is a black conservative
named Larry Elder, who has a long history
of disgusting comments about abortion, about
gay rights, about so many different things
he appeared on.
I guess this is yeah, this is the Kandace
Owens Show, which I guess is part of Prager.
You, Dennis Prager, part of Prager, you and
Larry Elder, the guy who, if it's not going
to be Gavin Newsom, has the best shot at being
the next governor of California, said you
can make the case that slave owners should
have gotten reparations when slavery ended.
Let's take a listen to this together,
Speaker 5: right behind that.
By the way, when you mentioned that the UK
was ahead of us, they were do you know that
the slave owners were compensated after they
lost their, quote, unquote, property?
The government compensated slave owners?
I didn't know.
Yeah.
And so when people talk about restabilization.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's fascinating.
Kandace is really learning a lot here, huh?
Speaker 5: They really want to have that conversation
because like it or not, slavery was legal.
And so they're property.
They're legal.
Property was taken away from them after the
after the civil war.
So you can make an argument that the people
that are owed reparations are not only just
black people, but also the people whose, quote,
property Close-cropped quote, was taken away
after after the end of the civil war.
Speaker 1: Isn't that just amazing, guys?
Now, he says you can make the argument.
There's lots of arguments that can be made
but shouldn't be made.
It's sort of like we're just asking questions
where, yeah, it's an innocuous enough phrase,
but sometimes the questions you're asking
and and the and the questions you're not asking
and the answers that you're presenting, it's
all very toxic and manipulative.
Now, by the way, slave owners got reparations
after the Civil War.
It's not just that what Larry Elder is saying
is vile.
It's not just that there could be nothing
more retrograde than electing as governor
of California of any state but of California,
because that's where we're actually looking
at a recall here.
It would be crazy to put a guy who talks about
reparations for slave owners in the governor's
mansion in California.
Slave owners got reparations after the civil
war.
On April 16th of 1862, President Abraham Lincoln
signed the District of Columbia Compensated
Emancipation Act.
The law prohibited slavery in the district,
and it forced its 900 odd slaveholders to
free their slaves.
And the government paid the slave owners about
three hundred dollars per slave.
That's like eight grand in in modern money,
inflation adjusted.
Now, that wasn't in every state, but we've
seen reparations for the slave owners and
it's all pretty damn crazy.
Now, during the same interview, I want to
look at one more clip of this.
Larry Elder also added, Black people get longer
sentences, but for legitimate reasons.
He he likes the fact that there is a sentencing
disparity for the same crimes along racial
lines.
Quite a guy, huh?
Speaker 5: He hired Eric Holder, his AG, who
once said when it comes to matters of race,
America is a nation of cowards.
And Eric Holder has called voter ID an example
of pernicious racism.
All right.
He's called the fact that blacks get longer
sentences and they do so for legitimate reasons,
that judges take into consideration your entire
criminal history.
You call that example pernicious racism.
He called the fact that black boys get kicked
out more often than white boys do in schools
an example of pernicious racism, never mind
their behavior.
This guy has been a more dangerous race card
hustler, in my opinion, than even Jesse Jackson.
And Al Sharpton is good at it.
Suit and tie speaks calmly and people have
much more.
Speaker 1: So there it is, guys.
It is black conservative quote.
Conservative Candice owns learning from black
Republican Larry Elder about why it makes
sense that black boys would get harsher sentences
for the same crimes than white boys.
This is the leading alternative to Governor
Gavin Newsom to become the governor of California.
So just a reminder.
Fortunately, Gavin Newsom has been pulling
away now leading keep Gavin leading by almost
10 points over.
Remove Gavin.
But everybody in California must vote, we're
going to have live coverage of results to
the extent that we get them on the same day
next Tuesday, and I hope you will join me
for that